ladies and gentlemen we have made it to the end
of witcher is the end this is the end this is the
end of the witcher valley season two done with the
show we're never coming back so enjoy it even no
matter how much you end up enjoying this episode
we're never coming back good riddance goodbye
to your witcher all right well hit that like
button if you're excited for us to never return
subscribe and click that notification bell so
you don't get notified when we don't cover the
spin-off series nor season three of the witcher
also our full-length watch-alongs where you sync
up with the time code something people do not seem
to apparently listen to when i say that are over
at our patreon page yes come over there join our
patreon check out all the shows we have to offer
or at the same tier you get the option for
many shows that have reaction highlights
and watch alongs where you sync up
with the time code included if you
ask for a refund after not realizing that
i said do you sync up with the time code
then that is on youtube that's on you we'll
still give this because for some reason you're
just not listening we had some messages i had to
handle today and anyway guys listen the boys have
prepper you guys rock i'm excited for you guys
not to edit our reactions for season three of
the witcher because we're done with this show
entirely hate all anyway guys can't wait for
season three excited for when that comes
out but let's finish off season two first
this is a dream it's gonna be a nightmare if
you don't rub that sleep from your eyes and get
moving the knighting ceremony started 20 minutes
ago and your grandmother has your dance card
full you know what's up what are you doing it's
really here it's all just a terrible dream nice
is this the banquet from the first episode
probably it's gonna come full circle
take the dagger with you
you're so mad at me please don't be mad i'm sorry
i've chased you all the way back here looking for
your validation look i know this means nothing
to you but i understand now how special she is
i don't know what vollis may wants from siri
but we have to protect him i have to protect
her i think it's pretty clear what vol if mir
wants with her i mean he's got that elder blood
oh
man she's just taking them all out
that's the meow
siri what's going on yo these witchers lack
serious awareness of their surroundings some
kind of security protocol anything how did you
escape i screamed and that didn't cause any damage
hit her rip her face off tell me what you want
ouch
wow uh-oh convergence
symbolism i don't know what it just seems
so goofy to me look how awesome we are
get anyone who's left merrick she got married too
it's my spare can of whoop ass right here all
convinced well if mere to leave siri's body
once the demon's out when she's
back in her corporeal form
or trapper would it work i don't know
but our best chances together listen
please trust me can we trust you i don't
know i think that's going to try to kill her
thanks a lot jennifer it's all your
fault he told me his target was nilfgaard
i never would have thought this is not
your doing i need you to gather some horses
about from the extraction or separation
family would do it yes it would
if you had your magic which you don't if i
had my [ __ ] magic instead i'll have to make
do with whatever i find in a witch laboratory
chemistry i pull siri into this mess and i'll
do everything i can to get her out of it she
needs her best friend fine gerald give him the
jasper make him love me hang on what are you
gonna do what witches do best make a potion
so her body is being controlled
right now but in her prison of her
own mind she thinks she's having
a glorious time at this banquet
and what the witch is doing is stabbing
people yep slasher movie killing spree
as a member of the royal family is it too much
to expect that you exercise to come off respect
it's not respectful then to rep your
highness would you want me with a dance
she would have loved to martin marty so much
brighter i know than uh how it was in that first
episode yeah it's the brightest most saturated day
there can be no mistakes when amber and me arrives
just fragile the killer put that on
a t-shirt the baby gave them hope
a reason to live rather than die fighting now
they're off to raise the kingdoms of our enemies
what are you saying i'm saying it
what that's what's up your plan
you're welcome you should rebirth that baby
from the get-go oh i would never do that you
said it yourself fringella when amir arrives
i need to rave so let me little bit of ecstasy
oh [ __ ] let's get it on elixir party chug chug
oh i think they're gonna have to kill her
oh
she is a powerful one what the [ __ ] damn siri
another one bites the dust
oh that could go on all day yeah full
let's mirror knows how to use serious power
oh no oh there's two of them
oh oh poor guy they ganged up on
him he put up such a good fight
come on you ask here get the
sorcerer's stone over there
owie
girl jennifer told me to give you this it's
it's balance and heat and oh you can't hear me
oh no never get to me
siri you can fight this stay strong siri
no
oh what is she doing she's scourging all the
babies there are many elves left in redania are
you sure there'll be no moving forward without
retribution are they murdering all the babies
yeah it's like a passover of elven vengeance
this show hates babies baby hates them
well the elves just got a
whole lot more interesting
and one fell swoop jesus christ
oh seriously oh [ __ ] this
looks like the cup of a carpenter
more
it's from the jurassic park portal
gross
wow oh [ __ ] balls nice oh there's a roller
coaster of some very pulpy gore in this episode
you kill her you kill siri
oh my god she can repair the dress too
our hate is the pain she needs to grow
stronger let's not give her what she wants
let's look at the positives here
there's a lot going for us right now
come on i've missed you so much
did you i don't think you really knew them
yeah you know in a distant sort of way if you can
hear me if you can hear us come home stay with us
i'm not going anywhere i'm not going anywhere
oh what a cool shot she needs a vessel to exist
within this sphere sir he can't escape unless
oh no jennifer i can be the vessel no for her
it's a hell of a transition shot man
what's gonna happen to yf if you can pull monsters
through the monolith you can send one back again
wicked
she's leaving why
uh nas school are coming
the army of darkness is coming join us your
place is among us you are ours time to scream
huh this wasn't too bad for
jennifer yeah all things
the wild hunt yes you can play
video game if you want to learn more
and also check out the
shadow of the wolf on netflix
no way
oh she back now set this place on fire
princess cerella created far less trouble for
us when she was dead put a bounty on the girl
and anyone who protects her good idea damn it the
elves are up in arms of the death of their baby
nilfgaard is stoking the ranger to foster another
war in the north will no doubt take the bait
we will be focused on getting the girl wow
i haven't met you down again was it worth it
instead of seeing what they really were and it
led to a mass grave we dug ourselves i don't want
revenge i want justice now you're talking my name
is history i'm a mage i have some information i
think could help you princess cirilla of sintra
she's one of you the one that he prophesized
he's saying she could save us oh
at least someone wants her for
something nice yeah not a [ __ ] hell i know
i've hurt you yet i can't help but wish you
could begin again use your knowledge of
magic to train the girl you're the only
person who's helped to control her powers
as if i'd trust anyone else with her hmm
how did you convince them to
fight by killing their home
we lay the blame on medina just pick that up
desperate times desperate measures desperate
indeed that's how i felt when i realized i
could no longer count on you i'm the one who
ordered the death of that elven baby it was the
best path to helping me find my daughter oh no
oh oh damn cool all this time we just
thought it was some [ __ ] [ __ ] turns out
we've met him before i think there's a
post credit scene good just freeing my ears
i think it's the trailer for the spin-off
series oh i'm so excited what's it
that's about when this
oh yo yo
get that dramatic cover
oh we're going back to the blood origin are we
going back to the times of the elders i'm going
to tell you right up front right now all the
work that goes into editing down these reaction
highlights and just putting the whole video
together that song's not going to be in there
with who copyright popular
seconds of a trailer i don't know
it looks cool i thought the episode was awesome
i thought the episode itself was awesome yeah
quite a thrill yeah quite a thrill
yeah it was cool that was great
all righty all righty that was a good one man that
was exciting i like that more than the last season
finale in a lot of ways actually because uh you
know it's like i like a big battlefield fight but
i thought like having it all intertwined into
you know like something i felt like a real
personal conflict for all of our characters
as opposed to them all being separated
like obviously the most interesting stuff is all
the stuff that's happened to kare morin uh with
you know like vesamir being not super conflicted
he seems like i know the reason why killing this
[ __ ] is because i'm [ __ ] careful yeah i seem
to go along with geralt pretty easy um but yeah
like the witchers dying uh i wish i got to know
them a little bit better so i could kind of care
it was awesome when they first started getting
stabbed i was like i think those are the witchers
you yeah those are the ones that are
always in the background that we never
spend enough time with you just flush out
the what remaining nine of them or whatever
yeah so i wish we got to know them a little bit
better but i'm also okay because they've done such
a good job of fleshing out the other characters
so that was the most enticing stuff but you know
even some complaints that we had about the last
episode like one thing i was you know one thing
that i thought we were um really echoing amongst
each other was that we were hoping that a lot of
that would pay off in this episode i thought it
did there's a lot that was set up here that had
like everything was so high stakes in this one and
just amped up to 11 like they really put the pedal
to the metal on this one it was so high octane
on like every story line even the elf storyline
escalated but my main takeaway is that mouse
sack is always just gonna be brought back
as some alternate evil version of himself that
poor guy he's such a sweetheart that mouse sack
and every time he comes back now just a [ __
] up version of mouse it's gonna feel worse
and worse and longer and longer ago that we
actually saw just an unperverted version of
him that was authentic yeah yeah he's gonna get
consistent work playing messed up versions yeah
but yeah no it was cool dude it was cool you know
i i don't the the motive of vol with mayor wanting
to get back home seems a little bit muddy but
we're not supposed to understand fully the context
of it all or does it stay from another
sphere does that mean like another
essentially their their language of another
dimension is that what you're getting at another
realm or something that's that's how i've been
taking it anyway yeah but it's not the same earth
i don't think so i yeah that's where i get to be
like it's planetary the way they no yeah the way
they describe it it makes me feel like okay yeah
they must just be like adjacent to dimensional
realms or something and yeah like this doesn't
look like like some kind of overlay where it's
like oh we're where we were in karamorin but this
is just this sphere's version like yeah i thought
it was just like a totally different place in time
yeah yeah i thought uh the actress would play siri
did such a cyrilla no wait siri both yeah zero
all of the above cersei is the authorship yeah
the actress who plays siri is did such a great job
here you know like i i get often distracted when
actors are forced to play like possessed versions
because they usually all play it kind of they play
it evil yeah and i thought you just kept noticing
you're you're doing a pretty good job this is
like a believable version where you're playing a
character still you're not just playing evil note
and the the conflict at hand i thought was
really interesting because geralt is kind of
outnumbered by motives around him like no one
really wants to save her uh it's like this it
seems even i'm sitting there at a certain point
in the show when like these witches are having
basilisks bite their faces and heads off it was
just killers but at a certain point you got to
look at the greater good my friend yeah because
i found myself getting in that debate as well
oh [ __ ] maybe you just gotta like off this girl
because this is not doing an old card plan at all
and i think there's a lot of people who are gonna
die because of it i like chaos i like the i like
uh you know i don't mean that as a pun i do like
chaos i like the crumble of of stuff and i think
it like to have it you know come to a place of
such personal spots like this takes place at care
more in the this episode where this is like where
witchers are created this is where geralt's home
is that's where he's supposed to go for refuge and
rest yeah and we got anything but this one yeah
this is just another [ __ ] never come back it's
off rebuild i mean the way i thought yeah we got
to comment on it with jennifer thought she got her
powers it's a little silly it's a little clean and
convenient it happens so rapidly you know possess
transport oh oh hey she just want to go back
i thought like oh damn you kill her off or or is
it going to be like she gets the magic back on
a minute or yeah or she becomes you know the full
form of volithmere or you know in getting back to
and delivering her to her home realm maybe that's
the extent of the magic and then she comes back
and doesn't have it or something like that so
yeah i mean it is a little bit clean and that's
exemplary of something that you know i feel like
could have been maybe smoothed over in you know
like this season has felt a little more show-like
a little bit more sort of plot-oriented and i feel
like some of those earlier tones from the first
season of just the more poetic exploration of
the story and the more sort of wilting uh pace and
alignment of the different timelines like i think
maybe that could have smoothed things over with
yen but you know as far as the priorities of the
episode go you know like it wasn't a major gripe
but it was something that felt kind of convenient
given like the second they arrive as already the
embers are dissipating out and the wild hunt is
coming and we're sort of on to the next thing
yeah i think the season finale of the first one
ended um i like that as you put at the poetic town
more of season one like once you know geralt and
siri when they arrive together and they embrace
each other like that's such a great moment or when
uh jennifer unleashes her chaos magic like the
way that's all realized i love the mood of that
more whereas there are things in this season
and even it really actually showed a lot in
this episode especially yaskir like the
way they handled the comedy with him felt
like he was this sort of breath of fresh air
i felt in the light i like him a lot don't go
wrong i still love you always happy yeah i'm
always happy when he's around but the way they
do handle his comedy now i feel like it it
does feel a little bit more like television
comedy or something writing yeah you've got to get
the mcguffin in there they're punching this script
up yeah yeah we got him in here people love to ask
you whereas i always kind of liked this show when
i was a little bit more lost because of the novel
language that this strikes you know yeah and the
sense of overall space i mean there's something
the season two is definitely crunched down is like
the sense of where everything is very far away
whereas now everything feels very close together
that's true it weirdly is even though they kind
of went a little bit to other more places it
felt smaller yeah it took like way less time to
get to any of them and and it's like i think it's
like you can do those things maybe in the same
episode but i think just decoupling from that
timeline uh you know variance of the first season
does kind of hamper that because then it feels
like you know every consecutive scene is kind of
happening in a similar linear time well it's like
a game map yeah yeah it is hey yeah it's a good
point it's like when you play those you know open
world games you're like [ __ ] this taking forever
to get there yeah nice forevers it would take in
real life you know you can't turn on fast forward
watching yeah upgrade to transporting yourself
places yeah so yeah i thought that was cool and
then the way it ends off with jennifer and geralt
going to watch over the number one target in the
world right now like this ended with everyone
just going who need to capture her we need her
she's the king to marry her to everybody to get
her back she's my daughter we need to she's she's
this is the key to restoring the elven glory yeah
to bringing monsters through and reigning on
everything she's everything this is her show
more than it is anyone's show at this point it's
her show this is all like every plot line centers
around her so i like seeing where it's where it's
coming together ultimately um and i don't really
have a complaint about any of this i thought like
the action was exciting i thought that yeah the
basketball is coming through was really cool the
effects were great the effects are awesome both
the cg and the practicals i mean some of those
gore gags and things and i mean they really
leaned into especially like in the final scene
where all the monsters are coming through and
there's the wind in the portal but even two when
the wild hunt shows up i was getting some like
wraiths the wraiths yeah the nazgul uh i was
getting certain like if army of darkness was more
intent on being actually badass kind of vibes like
those sort of pulpy horror-y uh you know medieval
vibes yeah that was funchy like that yeah it's
got that kind of like you know crazy whooshing uh
angles and stuff and you know just the plates of
bones and everything it got me excited for season
three like it yeah it didn't it did for as much
as the show like i think evidently feels a bit
different now and they too i mean it was nice
at first i thought i was gonna complain about
the way they dealt with dealt with the mirror
because i was like oh he's building this guy up
all season long man he's white flames everyone's
salvation but he's also kind of sinister who's it
going to be and then by the end i was like oh yeah
i've been sitting here being like is he ever going
to show up and i thought that was a was a pretty
appropriate punch too you know i definitely did
not see that coming that reveal certainly raises
some [ __ ] questions yeah it does oh why is it
where have you been this whole where has duty
been they must have told some lie to siri about
why they left yeah did uh did uh you know siri's
grandma she hadn't have anything to do with that
probably just tell them to lie um but yeah knowing
their bloodline and such but then you have uh you
know i like what they ended up with fragility
here where they think they've done the ultimate
service i like that they're caught on a lie right
away and i thought that strengthened the the
uh deathless mother the volath mirror story two
because it does come back to bite frangilla like
it is a deceit to everybody yes and that pays off
in a long-term way whereas some of the deathless
mother stuff felt like it could have been a little
more proportioned i thought that was a really
nice uh tie up for for her in that yeah cause
she never realizes the truth about that situation
and then of course you got the elves here uh
where wow that was mean that was really mean
but yeah [ __ ] humans they're all horrible we
are a bad bunch we are horrible we don't i feel
like yeah we're american we're the worst and i
feel like that endures through so much fantasy
novel reasons like humans and elves man we
were just always treating them like second
class shitty people where like elves have like
so many wonderful abilities and things you would
i i'm often kind of amusedly baffled by how much
hate elves get in these things well because they
represent purity in a lot of ways and we're
the uh destruction of all that we are the
body we are sin yeah yeah that's who we are man
we are we are absolutely it's true because uh
man that sucks it's like every every fantasy thing
is like men are evil but they're also our saviors
and those ones are worth lifting up there's
some cliffhangers that were cool you know uh
freaking baldy with the black girl owls my dude
awesome he's gonna stay bald next season he's
making sure he's both sustaining a bald old guy
and then uh some people know me around virginia
my dome the fire guy and uh messed up facebook
that was such a weird un like to talk about just
throwing something into your mail mainly
to just set yourself up for another season
i was like the one that was just here to set
something up i thought you could have saved that
for the season three premiere yeah yeah like i
like i like rants and i like you know her and i'm
all for like yeah let's get weird like messed up
you know more b-movie characters in here but also
it was like here's one scene and that's it that's
the only involvement they have this whole episode
i like that this all maintained a snowy landscape
throughout like the first episode took place at
night with it's like a good visual bookend where
the first episode took place on a snowy night
with its you know very blue lighting that this
has when it's nighttime and then uh this one ends
on that note with our main characters there too
you know except now it's not uh not them having
to come together yeah they're already together
and i just gotta get some questions answered
no they're family they're a family and they
got some things to work through yeah they got
counseling to do yeah but not a care morning i
gotta get the [ __ ] out the hell out of there
and it was nice to spend the whole
season kind of with caremoren
i thought that one of all the places we've been i
don't know of all the places we've been we've been
to some places where we've been like this place
seems like it would have been more significant
than people in the comments were like oh yeah
that place is way more significant in the book
so you know have kermore actually be
that was kind of nice you know i thought
vesimir
was a little under reused he does have kind of
one conflict to keep going back on for a lot of it
i thought he could have been they
could have showed some of his
cooler sides to for lack of a better word
they because i'm taking care of business
yeah because he's just kind of usually like
sad or [ __ ] girls go on the show he's
tortured yeah yeah and he's always he
is it seems like most of his conflicts are
vessemer you're blinded by fear and rage stop it
come back around i am geralt i'm the calmest dude
here and i can whoop your ass yeah you taught me
well i don't even need to look at you when i'm
fighting yeah yeah yeah it would have been and
i mean you know i i i really liked him as a
character but i do i do agree with you there
i feel like we could like the performer more
than like the writing of it yeah i felt like
we could have really seen through that character's
actions like oh yeah this guy is the father of the
witchers all essentially the remaining witchers
where you know he feels more like an uncle yeah
it's like if they were gonna go the path where
he is like uh his his days are long behind him
and he's lost hope and he just cares about staying
i thought they could like lean more into that then
like like pick a lane and just really commit to
that where i didn't get the full effect of either
it kept ending on him just being like kind of just
keep [ __ ] up i'm just gonna say it all the time
me and my ever dwindling number of witchers
which what are they now down to like four i know
it's more great to it than that that i'm what i'm
verbally communicating right now so i know i'm not
giving enough credit it i'm just giving a general
consensus here about how i felt it not best fear
overall like the performer a lot yeah uh but
i could have used yeah something that gives a
little bit more of that like badass edge to him
especially with the excitement of watching him
come in here with you know netflix and you
guys watching with the wolf yeah watch this
movie where he's a total man yeah or he's the lead
character yeah he's the one who trains gerald yeah
yeah and well yeah i think if they had had more
moments for him to actually you know really get
in geralt's head and have geralt wondering
like oh am i in the wrong i feel like most
of the time geralt's pretty much like no i know
it's the right thing man yeah gary let's call him
yeah where if he had maybe had a bit more sway or
influence or more ideological you know uh back and
forth with carol yeah it could have been cool
no i completely agree it was definitely missing
for me and this happened this uh season overall
but you know some cool [ __ ] some cool monsters
some cool action some cool effects i think i still
like season one more um to be like there's there's
things about this that are sharper and more punchy
and it's this one is easier to be entertained by
because of the rhythm the pace they simplify
a lot more of their dialogue they're aware of
audience feedback they're aware of like okay
i just send to them book readers yeah yeah
well now i'm just like reading the comments
i wonder what season three will be like maybe
they'll come to a middle ground because this
season people have been like they're not in
the books at all anymore like full of mirrors a
totally made up thing for this yeah because i went
on rotten tomatoes um recently and i was surprised
that i i wasn't made privy to this uh i went right
to because because i was complaining about because
we had our complaints about the penultimate
episode and i wanted so i went out to raw tomatoes
to be like what are people saying about this and
then i saw that the the critic score is higher for
this show than season one is like significantly
but damn the audience score is significantly
lower and it was just kind of on par with the
original season's critic score isn't like in
the 60s or something i think uh what the show
no the audience yeah uh audience receiving it's
pretty low yeah like not like terrible but it's
low this is definitely drop yeah i think that's
why you don't really hear as much talk about this
season as you do the other one because yeah
and it's just funny to say some [ __ ] and
then you know just because because what um
enticed me to go check it out was because
i saw some comments of people being like
the way you guys talk about it is just
some stuff we were saying was apparently
reflecting upon some people who actually had read
the books of like i feel like they're not really
following we were saying like i feel like they're
not really following book stuff anymore just based
off the way the show's being written yeah you can
even the way they do their action now
which felt feels less real and brutal
yeah a lot of times it's just so hyper stylized
or sometimes it's really cool yeah and other times
it's like just so wacky yeah at times i am like
let's go back to that first episode with just
that choreography and punchy camera work like
because people have said you know like this
season especially they were like in the books he
doesn't really fight that many monsters in general
so we're gonna have a like a monster of the
week to kind of add to that but i feel like that
creates a certain opportunity for that kind of
action whereas i feel like part of what made you
know the action the first season so gripping was
that half of it was just very tangible stuff you
know that was very personal and human based oh
yeah there's a lot of like cgi enhancements in
the fights yeah and sometimes it's totally fine
in my part in my opinion and other times it's
not that great but yeah there
are there are things about
i would say contextually what i liked about this
finale more just from the i the concept of you
know boiling it down to we're not hopping between
like a big battle and here's gerald's on the phone
and then we got like this is like pretty contained
everyone converges to some extent it was all
centered around a very personal conflict and then
it ends on a note of a very personal ordeal where
everyone's afters here the world wants siri and
this all continues that progression of tying into
her importance moving forward yeah and then
i think the actress who plays her is up for
the task of holding such an important character
yeah in this series they're all great they're all
fantastic all right guys well here we are we're
done we did it we'll be back for season three
don't worry i know some people don't pick up on
my sarcasm hopefully it won't take as many years
for it to come out now yeah i got a spin-off show
coming woo michelle yo let's do this also i don't
really that's another show literally nothing about
that that was like okay it looks like information
i feel like every one of these networks needs to
pump the brakes and go hey hey maybe just pour all
your resources into the flagship show before you
go spinning things off cinematic universe because
yeah before you go hey we're already running out
of book material let's keep that going that's
there you go hey hopefully it's good hopefully
it's good hey guys let's end this with a pay
spencer running with you because this is the final
episode of witcher but this is the first time
you're pledging i think is it i think we don't
know maybe sometimes people sign up with just
their first name and it gets confusing well here's
what i'm gonna do i'm gonna look at what the name
spencer means right now do it spencer spencer name
meaning steward oh means stewart or administrator
john you got 25 seconds to work with that
all right well hey if there's anything that's
important in a in a medieval inspired world it
is the stewards for they call so many shots they
keep aligned so many facts and details about their
realms and that's what you do for us spencer it's
all for you you are the steward the administrator
of the real rejects and that's a lot of
responsibility so uh we appreciate you for putting
that in much love buddy and hey stay pledged
and i'm going to continue shouting you out
cause i didn't really times your time's up
you've messed up your shout out stay pledged
because i'm going to give you a better shout out